hey guys let's start lesson six so in
this lesson we're going to be taking
everything we've learned so far and
we're going to be building three more AI
web applications these three web
applications are going to use Python
they're going to be really
straightforward in order to code we're
going to use basic scripting that we've
learned so far in the previous lessons
and these three AI web applications are
all going to be for construction use
cases so we're going to build the first
one which is going to be for civil
engineers which is going to take a bunch
of site photos which you've uploaded or
taken when you're walking around the
site you're going to be able to upload
those and you're going to be able to
automatically generate a draft word
report um of the inspection summary so
it's going to highlight key uh things
that it sees in the photos summarizing
them highlighting potentially some
hazards that have been spotted and we're
going to be able to download that as a
draft word report we're then going to
build another web application which is
going to be for contractors and this is
going to take a PDF Construction
contract and it's going to write out any
it's going to create a table of the key
risks with that contract so it's going
to tell you which Clauses could be
unfavorable to you what page those
Clauses are on and a kind of severity
score um on how unfavorable that Clause
is to you we're then going to be
building a final web application which
is actually my personal favorite which
is um an AI uh tool for
Architects which is going to take uh
some photos which you've uploaded of a
building it can be there exterior or it
could be interior rooms and you're going
to be we're going to automatically
restyle the the style of that building
based on uh just a prompt so you'll be
able to take a a photo that you have of
an old-fashioned room and it's going to
be a to restyle that and modernize it
and kind of refurnish it for you so also
going to be able to switch between
different architectural Styles uh and
this is going to use a stable diffusion
model so we have these three different
new uh AI web applications we're going
to be building um and hope you're really
looking forward to this course guys it's
the final practical so let's get
started okay guys so without further Ado
let's get started then so um head over
to the notion page your notion training
page and click on lesson
six uh from here what we're actually
going to do just to get started started
um is we're going to do some finishing
touches to this AI for CAD tool that we
were building in the last lesson but if
you're just jumping into this lesson
straight away um you might want to skip
this section onto when we're actually
doing uh we're building the next
application so we're just going to be
finishing off some code that we were
working on in the last lesson because
what I want to show you here is just how
we can add a little bit more python to
generate a CSV file from the work we
were doing in the last lesson so um what
we're going to do here is we we already
have our blueprints dopy file which we
were working on in the last lesson so if
you remember our blueprints P file is
within our folder for our blueprints
analysis app and what we were doing is
we were adding different lines of code
in here different lines of streamlit
code in order to build our web
application so we didn't need many lines
of code at all actually we only needed
66 and the way in which our our code was
being executed was it was going line by
line so each one of these lines of code
was being read and uh in turn it was
building our web application so what
we're just going to do here is if you
remember our application generated at
the end a table so we had our open a
open a API key up here we've uploaded
our photo which is uh actually a
blueprint in this case um and then we we
you can see our blueprint in here you
can see which prompts being sent off
here to open AI API which is telling it
to create a takeoff of the quantities of
this engineering drawing returning a
table and here's our table that was
being generated but what I want to do
here is I want to read this into a CSV
file because this will be more useful
than me needing to copy and paste this
and perhaps um then building the table I
will do this automatically and then be
able to just send this table off um
after reviewing it let's say so what I'm
going to do here is I am going to add a
few more lines of code and these lines
of code are going to be for generating
the markdown table so what you can do is
you can actually just copy and paste
this whole block and just replace all
the code in blueprints dopy but what I
want to show you here is I want to show
you uh just go going line by line so
what we have here is we have markdown
table to CSV so what we're generating
from our open a code is a markdown table
um and what we want to do is we want to
use a script in order to convert that
into um into our CSV file and what we
already have here is some pre-written
code um that i' I found online for
generating taking a markdown table
format and what it's doing here is it's
just manipulating the different um this
markdown table string so it's like a
long line uh long line of uh letters
characters and what we're doing here is
we're just manipulating this
into into a um data pandas data frame so
as if you remember from our previous
lesson what we had was a data frame a
pandas data frame is just a way of like
holding uh data within our application
memory uh using python so this is just a
way of working with data and what we
doing is we're reading our markdown file
here and iterating through these
different uh lines of code looking for
where the table cells start and end so
essentially this is what this block of
code is doing here it's just like
searching through and it's finding those
um those cells and reading those into a
data frame so you can you can read
through this and try to understand sort
of more on the logic side in the maths
we're basically using this for Loop here
to read through the table and write it
into a data frame um I'm not going to
explain exactly how the logic in here
Works in terms of how it's reading this
out but you're welcome to like break
this down and kind of understand it more
deeply but we're just going to be using
this script uh here for generating
markdown table uh markdown table to CSV
what we're then going to do is um double
check that we have all our libraries
that we need I think that we probably do
here um yes so we have eight and and D
just double checking they're all we we
have them all here so what I'm going to
check is where I'm using this markdown
table to CSV section which is down here
at the bottom so what I'm doing here is
I'm um getting our response message I'm
still printing this out uh like I was
before but I'm going to be doing one
extra thing which is I'm going to be um
basically taking this so this is where
we're printing out our response message
with streamlit SST do mark down this is
where our response message is coming out
in this sort of assistant chat block
that streamlit conveniently has for us
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
grab this final bit of code and I'm just
going to explain this to you so what
this is basically doing here is it's
taking this entire response message
we're getting back from uh open Ai and
it's going to apply this function that
we've just created and defined above so
it's really important that we Define
this above because the way that python
executes is it goes from the first line
line one and executes each line
simultaneously so we need to put this
function above where we're using it so
it needs to have found this function
before we're calling it because
otherwise if we put this below if we put
this function below it's not going to
know where this fun what this function
is because it's not got to that line of
code yet so we have to put this
above and uh we're then reading in this
response message that we've received
back from open AI um into this markdown
to CSV
converter function we then taking this
data frame that we get back so the
output of this is the pandas data frame
and we're then using a function which is
in the pandas Library which is 2 CSV so
this is why we want to put it into this
pandas data frame because it has lots
it's a big library has lots of
convenient functions for us to use in
this case we're just using the one for
converting it to a CSV and it's doing
all of that hard work inside that
function for us so again building on
open source libraries we don't need to
do all of this ourselves because um this
will be lots of lines of code we'd have
to write um we're then doing a bit more
um we're giving some extra parameters in
here I won't go into these too much but
we're doing some sort of encoding here
as well um this would be in the in the
documentation that you'd need to add
this so um I won't explain those too
much but then basically we're using
stream list to create a download button
and within that download button we're
basically um adding our CSV and saying
that this is going to be a CSV file that
we're downloading in here so file name.
CSV and this here is also saying that
it's going to be a CSV uh CSV file uh
icon that's showing so this is it great
so we have our button which is when we
press it we're going to download this
CSV file so let's go ahead and save this
now and what we're going to do is we're
going going to run this code uh locally
just to double check this is working
okay before we then push it to our web
application so if you remember we have
we we're going to run now a local
version of uh blueprints dop of our web
application but we also have the version
we were we we uh launched last uh last
week which is oh sorry in our last
lesson which is basically already on the
web so we're going to first just check
this is working locally and then we're
going to if it's all good we're going to
then push it onto the
web so let's just have a look at our
openai API key so we're going to grab
we're going to grab our open a API key
once again because we need this one for
putting into our web application and
this is now loaded up so I'm going to
put my going to put my openai API key in
there and I'm also going to grab a photo
of um our sample blueprint so I'm also
going to grab this one and I'm going to
upload this into our web application so
let me drag and drop this into images
and let's see if we now generate our our
table and also our CSV file so let's
check if we run into any errors okay so
it's all run and we have this but Buton
down here which could be restyled it
could be made a bit nicer actually we
could make this um a bit clearer that
it's a it's an actual uh call to action
it's naturual thing we can press but
let's just click this for now and see
what we end up with so we've got this
table. CSV file so we might also want to
reconsider uh renaming that cuz I mean
table. CSV isn't the most convenient
name and we can also do that in
streamlet but what we have here is our
CSV file that has been created now the
final thing I want to do here is I want
to push this code to my GitHub which
will automatically update the streamlet
app we already have on the internet
because right now I've made my changes
and I've just tested them on my local
machine so this isn't going to be
affecting the web application the one we
have on streamlit so I want to update
our GitHub which is already connected to
stream lip and it will automatically
update that as well so I'm going to do
that by pushing some new this new code
I've created to GitHub so the way I do
that is I type in these commands we
learned in the last lesson which is git
add a which is going to tell uh git that
we're adding you information I'm then
going to do git commit M and I'm adding
this commit message along with
committing this code and I'm going to
say add download um add CSV
download so basically I'm just
describing this commit that I'm doing so
I'm saying here get commit uh add CSV
download and then I'm then going to push
this to our GitHub so I'm doing git push
origin main which is again this command
we learned in the last lesson and so we
have some processing that happens it's
upload compressing uploading blah blah
blah and then it's successful so it's
pushed our new this is like the code the
the um key or the ID of this uh commit
that we've done and it's pushed it to
the main branch so this this was
successful so what I can do now is I can
go back to my GitHub um which is over
here and I can just check that
blueprints analysis app uh this
repository is updated so what I can do
is I can refresh and it will say here
now so it's basically and the number of
commits so now it's just been updated
now um and you can see here a list of
these different files in the repository
and here's our blueprints dopy file
which is the only file we updated and
you can see here it was updated 1 minute
ago so this is these changes have just
been reflected uh in our GitHub as well
so this is really nice because if we
have someone else working here they'll
also see our latest code as well um so
it's like a very useful for
collaborating okay now the next thing I
want to do is I want to update my
streamlet app so I'm going to go go over
to my app here I'm going in streamlet
make sure I'm on the apps page p and I'm
going to then reboot this application so
um obviously I receiv received the
warning here that this is going to
disrupt any users who are potentially
using the app at the same time um and
you see that here it's now it's now
rebooting so the app app is in the oven
and this could take a few moments you
can actually follow what's happening
down here um by by clicking that manage
app button and you'll see here what's
happening so it's actually like pulling
code changes from GitHub so you see here
it's updating itself what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to while this is
happening I'm just going to grab my
openai API key again and I'm going to
copy this because I'm going to just do a
final test of our application once this
is ready because I want to make sure
that um it's working on production how
it was in on our Local Host so you call
this production because it's our you
know it's our main app
app uh and I'm just going to drag and
drop this this drawing this CAD drawing
that we have and I'm going to send this
off to open Ai and see what we get
back so we see here we have
our uh drawing here and we have our CSV
file and this is downloading our table
so that's it guys we've done a good job
here we've generated our CSV table from
our CAD drawing and this is live on the
internet now now let's head back to our
notion training page and we're going to
move on to our next application so this
is going to be our AI for civil
engineering which is going to take our
site inspection photos and create a
draft uh word report based on those
photos so we've we've already got the
building blocks uh which we've covered
for building this application and you
probably have some idea in your mind how
to build this um but what we're going to
do is we're going to download this ZIP
file which is going to contain some of
these the template files that we need in
order to build this application and then
going to drag this file uh I'm going to
unzip this and I'm going to drag this
file to where I wherever I want to keep
it um keep my project documents I'm just
going to put it on the desktop now
because that's the easiest for me but
put it wherever you want um so here is
the photo to report app and just double
check that these are the files that are
in there I'm then going to go back to my
vs code and I'm going to create a new
I'm going to open a new window and now
going to go up to file and I'm going to
go open folder and I want to open the
folder where this code is kept so I'm
going to go to my uh desktop and I'm
going to open the blueprints analysis oh
no I'm going to open the photo to report
app so once this is opened you'll see
these different files uh files here on
the left
and what I want to do is I want to go
back to my notion P my notion um
tutorial and I want to um follow these
instructions so just to double check
that your your file structure should
look like this your project structure
then I want to go to terminal and I want
to create my virtual environment once
again so I'm going to copy this code
already python uh to create my virtual
environment where I'm going to install
my different
libraries and then then I'm going to run
that code so terminal new
terminal uh here's the command line and
we're going to copy that code in to
create our virtual environment this
going to take a a few moments to process
and you'll see this new file has just
appeared here which is VM so this is
file which is basically containing all
the information to do with our virtual
environment where these things will be
installed so this is now run uh this
code's now run and and I want to open I
want to activate my virtual environment
as well so this oh this is still
processing so just give it a little
while longer and I want to now copy in
my my code for activating this virtual
environment I'll see that's now started
because of this VM uh that we now see
over here so now all my code isn't going
to be all my libraries that I'm
installing and not going to be installed
on my whole computer just within this
virtual environment
I then want to go back to my notion
training page and I want to install
stream lip so I'm going to do pip
install so this is the way you install
libraries pip install streamlet so this
is um basically creating the installing
all the libraries I need for streamlit
within this virtual environment so not
on my my main not across my entire
computer next you may need to run this
pip install python dox this is going to
be a library that we're going to use for
um working with uh Word documents so
generating Word documents you might not
have this already installed um like over
your whole computer so you might need to
run python docx uh pip install python
docx um only if you receive this error
um and so the next thing I need to do is
I need to go to streamlit run photop pi
and I'm going to go back to VSS codee
and this is the code I need to boot up
my local so running on my local computer
the version of this site inspection
photos to draft report AI so this may
look quite similar we're using a very
similar user interface here to keep
things simple um and this is again a
streamlet application so let's go back
to our photo. py so we're going to look
at our photo. P file here and we're
going to look at exactly what's
happening here so a lot of this should
look quite familiar but I'm going to
talk you through this nonetheless so um
here we're installing our different
libraries here we're using our doc X
Library which is going to be uh or we're
installing it at least which is going to
be the library for handling our Word
documents you see here we're setting up
our page configuration so this is
streamlit streamlit code for creating
our page title so our web page title
we're then adding the title that we
actually see on the page itself so
inspection photos to draft report AI
assistant here's us taking our openai
API key once again in the same way we
have a a text input this time so we can
allow a user to actually enter a
prompt which would be um perhaps them
providing some extra information this
time um allowing them to say exactly
what they want from the photos what
details they want to
capture um from this bunch of photos
like what type of report they might want
to write what you want uh the AI to pick
out from the photos and write into this
word document we then have our image
input as well so we can accept multiple
files so this will be useful since we're
up we you could potentially need to
upload many photos from the site
investigation we then have our send
button so if this is pressed we're then
activating these lines of code which is
the same as a warning code once again so
this is going to be um basically us
checking to make sure there's some input
here and if not stopping the rest of
these lines of code activating and
providing a warning so if I just try
straight away here we're going to see
API Keys required so this is the first
line it gets to if I enter some type of
API key here just like dummy data you're
going to see it then passes this line
these lines of code and it's now
stopping here so um the authentication
for the API key happens on the open AI
side so here we're not it's not checking
if there's some correct API key that's
entered that will be done on the open a
end in this
case um we're then basically preparing
this message which we're going to be
sending over via the open AI
API iterating through these different
images making sure they are all images
so here we have once again the check uh
to see if it's these different image
file formats and if not a warning
message that also shows up we're
encoding our image um in order to
prepare this to send it to open AI in
the same way we did in the last lesson
while building this so we're converting
our image into binary data which can
then be sent over to this uh multimodal
uh model that open AI are using you see
here I've actually commented so these
are comments um I've actually commented
out the part where we were sending this
over to open AI because I wanted to just
test when I was developing this that
this was working uh so this is a useful
way of just like um deactivating lines
of code without deleting it you can just
comment it so here I'm going to do
control and forward slash which will
actually um comment and uncomment whole
blocks of code so I I tend to do this
when I'm rather than deleting code when
I want to test something so here I was
like to avoid cost I was basically
testing this app was working
but just with a dummy response message
so I'm now going to uncomment this and
I'm going to comment out my my um my
dummy message so this is like
deactivating it and just turning it into
a
comment um and then what I'm going to do
here as I'm going to um read back this
uh chat which has been sent by the user
so I'm using this chat message block
like in the last lesson with the user
you user um display kind of Vis visuals
um and here I'm then adding that message
that I'm sending plus this attached
image um then if I'm get receiving this
response message back from open AI API
I'm then basically put turning this into
a block of text uh with the with the
assistant message
bubble um and then this is the part
where I'm actually creating the word
document so here what I'm doing is I'm
creating a new Doc uh document using the
docx library so docx import document
here is where I'm setting that up so
this is like a doc X object let's say uh
where I'm then associating this to Doc
and then I'm using different functions
from the docx library from their
documentation to add things so I can add
a um a word heading which is AI
assistant response you can change this
however you want then adding paragraph
So the response message and then I'm
also adding in the images here so into
the document I'm also adding pictures so
you see here I'm using this block of
code to add a label saying attached
image I'm then um basically reading the
images in via some memory that I'm
allocating so I won't worry too much
about this but the bytes iioe is
basically me allocating some memory to
hold that image um whilst I'm doing
something with it so here I'm basically
putting this image into this word
document so if if this gets really big
sometimes like the server can run out of
memory but we we'll talk about that
maybe if we do a future um future course
as well so this is holding it in memory
here so this would add some limit to the
size of our application if this gets
really big but let's not worry about
that now and we want to then finally
create this into this download download
button here where this buffer which is
basically our Word file that's being
held in the memory of our application is
being stored so when someone presses
this download button we're going to grab
this whole word document that's in here
so I'm going to now test this out and
see what happens so I'm going to go back
to my open AI API key I'm going to grab
this one because it's working in the
same way as we did as we did last time
and I'm going to come to my site
inspector inspection photos to draft a
report AI assistant and what we already
have is some some um some photos that we
can use so here if we click sample
photos we've got two uh photos in here
of uh sea seaw walls um or some sort of
marine structures so what I want to do
is Imagine I've just gone on my site
visit and I I could have a lot more
photos than this but we're just keeping
it simple for now um I can grab those
different photos from my site visit and
I can drag these into my application and
upload them in
here so I can drag these across and I'll
just drop them in so I've got
0302 these two different site photos I'm
also now just going to get the prompt
that I want to use which is from here
which says basically right up a summary
of the seaw wall in this photo so it
always helps to give a little bit of
extra context about what um what this uh
multimodal AI is really going to be
looking at so we're saying here it's a
seaw wall um create a section for each
photo and for each section you should
include a general description of the
photo then a table with the following
columns risk description risk severity
always return this as plain text so I'm
going to provide this prompt and hit
send so now we can see that this is
running away and just to explain a
little bit while this is going on I say
here always always return as plain text
the reason I'm doing this is because
actually when we're um going to download
our document our word
report um basically what open AI is
returning to us here is something called
markdown so this is a for a special type
of formatting that's actually used a lot
on blogs and um this is the way that the
tables are created but with our library
when we create our Word document this is
going to not Translate cross perfectly
so what you'll see here is we've drafted
our initial Word document for our site
inspection report and you could see here
that we've got the first draft pretty
nicely in um but what you see is there's
some formatting happening here where
this is the markdown style so this is
like markdown uh
formatting and what we'd actually need
to do we've got everything we need here
but what we'd actually need to do to
make this a little bit better is we want
to remove this formatting and tidy this
all up but we're not going to do that in
this lesson um I'm just showing you
because it gets a little bit more
complicated then but what I'm just
showing you here is that you can create
this initial draft and you can actually
convert this from markdown into um you
know full formatting or even just
copying and pasting sections from here
however you wish but this is our initial
draft of our inspection report
now going back to our notion training
page we're going to move on to our AI
for contractors so this is going to be
an app to analyze Construction contract
risk so what we're going to do is the
same step as last time which is we're
going to download this contract uh
application we're going to open this up
in our
downloads um so we're then going to uh
unzip this file and we're going to bring
it to wherever we wherever we want to
use it so I'm actually going to store
this once again on my desktop and then I
basically want to come down to where
this uh application is so it's here
contract analysis app and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to go back to my VSS
code and I'm going to create a new
window and I'm going to navigate my way
over to this project once again so this
should be getting quite familiar now in
terms of how we first um set up our
projects and how we navigate around so
I'm going to go to my uh folder for this
contract analysis app and I'm going to
click
open I'm then going to do some of the
same steps that we did last time which
should be getting quite familiar now
which is going to be we're going to go
to our terminal we're going to go new
terminal and then we're going to go back
to our notion training page and we're
going to uh run some of these commands
so we're going to create our virtual
environment to start
with so while this is running I'll look
at the next instruction which which is
we're then going to activate our virtual
environment inside this project folder
and we can also check that the folder
structure also looks similar to this so
we want to check that we have all of
these files um that have copied across
or been unzipped so this looks correct
to
me so we're just going
to we're just going to run this uh
activation command on our virtual
environment so we see this is now
activated we're going to go to copy uh
we're going to install streamlit so
we're going to go copy this across start
installing
streamlet and we're going to look at
what else we might need so also in we
need to install open a for this project
and after this is all run I already have
open a installed uh after this is all
all has run we need to then uh run this
command streamlit run contract dopy
so we just want to also while this is uh
loading I'm just going to start to talk
you through um contract. and exactly
what we have here so this should look
quite familiar to our our code that
we've worked on previously so once again
we're building our streamlet application
and we will see here that we're setting
up our page streamlet with the page
title con Construction contract risk
assessment and renegotiation so this is
what this application is going to do
we're going to create a table with the
high uh with the risks identified in
this contract we're going to draft the
renegotiation email here we're adding
the title so streamlet markdown we're
creating the title which is Construction
contract risk assessment and
renegotiation then taking our open AI
API key once again we're then collecting
some text input so with this text input
we're adding the label project state or
country so this is going to be this you
can change this however you wish but
this is going to be we're going to be
using this in our prompt to basically
say what place we're in and what
jurisdiction um we want to try and
compare our Construction contract to we
then take our image input so we can
accept multiple images in this case
we're actually going to look at also
accepting PDFs in this um in this lesson
so converting PDFs into images because
it has to be images that we're reading
to open
AI uh I'm just now going to since this
is installed I'm now just going to um
run this app as well so I'm going to get
this just started in the background um
so we're also loading that up and you'll
see that now it's running on a local
server of mine but now I'm just going to
continue to explain what exactly is
happening
here so we're then loading in our button
so our send button so if we come back to
our
application oh we need a PDF plumber
installed so we also need to install um
we need to use pip install and the name
of this Library so PDF plumber so this
is going to be another Library which we
need to
install and we'll see this is now
starting to install so we'll continue
just to explain what's going on here so
what we have is we have we're rendering
our send button and then we're doing
once again our checks so seeing if we
have our API key and also if we have our
text input and image input if not we're
stopping the code from executing and
giving back a warning to the
user we're then setting up our prompt so
we're setting up our prompt slightly
differently this time in that we're
actually um we're actually here creating
a message and we're inserting the text
input so this is the text input we see
from up here which um the user inputs
and we're now putting this into our
prompts we're allowing the user to
customize a section of the prompt that
we're actually sending off so here we're
saying considering the prompt we're
using is considering the law in this
jurisdiction from the user and general
best practice for managing construction
contracts contract risk find the highest
risk Clauses and create a table
summarizing these risks um in the table
you must include columns as risk type
risk description risk severity see
article number page number so this is
very similar to the custom GPT we
created earlier write this table back to
me and then we're saying below the table
write a renegotiation letter outlining
my concerns with the terms and with
suggestions over fairer terms we'd like
to discuss further ignore any terms
which are non-negotiable like compliance
with local laws so this is the prompt
we're going to be using for our
application we're then basically
iterating through each one so we're
using a for Loop through each one of the
images that we've uploaded and we're
just checking here that this is in fact
an image file type or a PDF so you'll
notice at the end here we're also
allowing PDFs to be uploaded
here I'm going to stop here and I'm just
going to get the the application set up
and we're going to just have a look at
it now from this point on okay so now
we've opened up our application and you
can see once again open AI API key
project state or country and images but
what I want to do here is I want to
rename this not images but I want to
rename this um contract up contract
upload or something like this um because
now we realize that we don't actually
just accept images but also PDFs so we
want to let the user know that so we can
say here
Construction contract
upload and this is going to tell um this
is going to tell the user then that they
can actually upload uh their
Construction contract here we could also
put brackets and put the different file
types that are accepted that might even
make it even more clear so you could say
PDF um image PNG something like this um
or this should be like maybe jpeg
probably so this will give the user some
feedback in terms of what file types
they can actually upload here um which
will be useful to them so now what we're
what we're going to look at here is
we're going to look at some more let's
say not complicated but we're we're
handling different file types so what
we're going to do here is with the PDF
we're not actually going to we're not
actually going to read this off um as an
image what we're going to do is we're
going to try and extract the text as um
with a OCR uh model so this is PDF
plumber so this is a tool for extracting
or reading text from documents and so
we're reading this PDF and we're trying
to extract out any text and basically
append that text onto a message so what
we're doing here is we're saying for
page in all the PDF Pages we're going to
use a um basically something from the
PDF plumber Library so extract text
we're then also printing this text so
while it's being read out we might want
to get rid of this actually we probably
unless you want to read the text uh down
here in the terminal you can probably
get rid of that and then if there is
some text we're basically appending this
to this message content so we're we're
filling up the message content with all
of the pages of information the reason
we're doing this is because using our
basically using an image image approach
um if this is a huge contract we could
actually end up with with um a higher
bill here from uh using the image model
so with the image model um we're going
to use a lot more tokens so basically
we're converting the the image into raw
data and then reading that into sending
that into open AI so that's using a lot
of tokens which comes at a greater cost
whereas what we what we can do here is
we can use fewer tokens by just reading
the text rather than the image so this
is the approach we're going to do here
in fact you could perhaps even get rid
of reading images if you wanted to but
I've left it in here because this is
what we've been familiar with so far um
in case you want to just play around
with that option but be aware that if
you send lots of images to the open a
API it will start to charge you like you
know not an insignificant amount and
then we're doing our warning our typical
warning that if uh if it's not one of
those file types we're going to send
we're going to alert the user and stop
executing code we're then doing our
typical openai API call and we're
sending this to GPT 40 but actually we
could send it to 3.5 but just be aware
it wouldn't be as accurate um since in
this case for the PDFs we're just
sending
text uh so what we're going to do is
we're just going to test this one out
we're going to go back to our
application we're going to go to our API
key actually so we're going to copy
across our open AI API key once again
put this in here and then we're going to
type our jurisdiction so I think our
draft construction contracts that we're
looking at is in Colorado so we're just
going to go to sample contracts we're
going to open
this we're just going to have a quick
look um so this is the like an I
Construction contract with different
terms in here though which we want to
assess and we're going to bring this
into our application so we're going to
drag and drop this PDF in here and we're
just going to run this straight away and
see what we end up with so you see here
it started running and we're just going
to see if we get this back so we're
streaming the response back like we have
been before super fast and here we're
highlighting these different risks so
risk of payment delays so there's a
clause in there the severity of this
risk what the article number is so
that's the clause in the contract and
which page that's on also so reading
this out it looks very nice to me um
came back really
quickly and looks like a good first
draft as well um and what we have below
is our renegotiation letter so here we
have you know a nice intro saying that
there's a few concerns that have been
found we're eager to to proceed with the
project um it sounds very nice actually
and then uh there's some risks that we
need to discuss with you and then these
are all listed out so you can obviously
re review these yourself and check the
contract as well but this is a good
initial start so let's move on to the
next one The Architects AI which I'm
quite excited to
demonstrate okay so back on our notion
training page what um I need you to do
is move on to this next section so AI
for architecture and I want you to click
this first link so what we need to do is
we need to sign up for something called
replicate which is a um they host AI
models online which we can use there's
like stable diffusion models um all
sorts of different mainly image uh
related AI models and we're going to be
using one or two of these so I need you
to get uh set up um I need you to sign
in I don't think need to add a credit
card um you can get started using some
of these AI models for free so you just
need to set up an account at the time of
recording this training and then what we
need to do is we need to go up to our
account we need to go to API tokens and
then what we want to do is we want to
create our API token so you can create a
token name once you've created this
token I want you to I want you to just
leave it here actually but we're going
to have to copy this just make sure
you've got one created
um now what we're going to do is we're
going to go back to our training page
and we need to download a bit more code
so this is going to be the template for
our um Architects AI tool and we're
going to extract uh unzip this and we're
going to bring this file to wherever we
want so I'm putting it just on my
desktop then what we're going to do is
we're going to go back to VSS code and
we're going to create our um we're going
to create a new
window and we're going to do something
similar once again that we've been doing
so far this lesson which is we're going
to um basically go to where we've
extracted that code so on our desktop
and we're going to go to building
redesign app and we're going to open
this so your file structure should look
a bit like this you should have some
images in here you should have sample
photos and you should have the building
redesign app in here which is also going
to be a stream
application um let's go back to our
notion page and just make sure we're on
the ne Right Next Step so we want to go
to our terminal and then we're going to
set up our virtual environment once
again so we're going to want to go back
to our terminal to um and basically run
this to set up our virtual
environment and we're going to want to
activate it straight
afterwards so let's execute these lines
of
code so all activated now we're going to
want to do pip install
streamlit so that would be the next uh
step on our list installing
streamlit and we're going to want to
then run this application so streamlit
run build redesign dopy and then we're
just going to post that in here so
streamlit run build redesign um although
actually this needs to be building
redesign so you see here on the left
it's building redesign so we're just
going to run this uh code and it's going
to start our local uh web server so if
you've noticed with the last three
applications we've just ran these
locally but what we might want to do is
push you might want to push these to
GitHub to stream L but we won't be doing
that again we've already covered it but
just to be aware that these are all
local and what you'll see is that
applications loaded up here and this
looks a little bit different to the one
before so we're just going to explain a
little bit more on styling in this one
and how we can make our applications
look a bit nicer um so you see this one
I've added a bit more a bit more um a
bit more style let's say so we're just
going to go back to our Visual Studio
code and I'm going to explain exactly
how we have built this so if you'll see
here it's look will look quite familiar
we may need to rein we may need to
install replicate so that would be pip
install replicate if we if we haven't
already uh if we don't already have this
installed um so yeah need to need to do
that and we'd also we're also here
setting the page title so this looks
familiar also adding the title of a page
this looks familiar but what we have is
we have this sidebar over here so let's
just explain what's happening there so
what we have is this um other streamlet
function which is to create this sidebar
where we've actually put API key text
input image input so this would be our
API key which we already know this would
be a prompt describing how we'd like to
restyle the image that we have we then
have our image uploader so this would be
a single image this time that we're
uploading um and storing in this
variable and then if image input is not
none what we're doing here is we're
actually storing in a session so session
is almost like you can think of it as
like some sort of history or memory or
like a cookie in terms of um uh
something that we're storing uh this
image input into so we're saying image
um we're reading this image into this
session state so this is allowing us to
sort of create this sidebar where we're
going to store some
information um then what we have is we
have our function which um looks quite
familiar in terms of turning an image
into this base 64 so replica is quite
similar to um open AI in the sense with
their image models we're sending in in
this case we're going to be sending in
this base 64 data so we're sending in
raw uh binary data for the image rather
than the image file itself so um this is
just a function to take the an image and
to turn it into that base 64
data then what we have is we just have a
small section here on some styling so
this button we're using this like purple
button over here um we basically just
have a function there for a little bit
of styling to that so this is called CSS
um which is the way you kind of style
things on the web but I've just added
this here just so you can have a look
and maybe you can play around with the
color so this is like um a hex color
that you can change hex aimal color um
and you can change some of the style
here if you want to and start
understanding a bit about
CSS and then basically adding this um
adding this button uh to the to the web
page so you see here the buttons down
here
um then basically if this button gets
pressed we're then going to be check
doing our usual checks of if the API
Keys uh been entered and also if there's
some text within that image prompt or
the image
input then what we're doing is basically
getting the image input turning into the
base 64 format using this function here
um uh otherwise we're saying it's none
so image base 64 is none we're then
updating our session State once again so
you saw before we took the image session
State and now we're taking the text
input and API key and putting into this
session state so it's available
throughout all our application and not
just in this sidebar so this is like a a
way in which streamlit helps you to
divide up your different sections here
is by using some session session
State um so when the code's executing
you can grab this session State and
something else which might be separate
then what we're doing is we're creating
our prompt so image uh sorry input is
going to be the prompt and the image and
then this is following the replicate
documentation So This Is How They want
you to in interact with their
application they then um the way in
which you set up your API token is with
this so according to the replicate uh
documentation you're meant to use this
OS environment variable so you're
setting your environment variable of
replicate API token to be the API key
this is straight out of their
documentation on how to use their
API uh we're then selecting which image
model we want to use so this is the
image model I selected which is a stable
diffusion image
model and so if we want to have a quick
look at that we can go back to replicate
we can click dashboard um and this is
going to take us to where our different
um our different models are so what
you'll see here is this control n
uh AI model I've been using so this is
an image uh model which um is yeah based
on like a sort of staple diffusion model
and um the way this works is you can
take an old uh your your original image
it breaks it down into sort of segments
so it does some
segmentation um so you see here all
these lines and the cleaner this
segmentation the better you'll be able
to do the next phase of the generation
so this is that's a really key step and
then here is restyling based on the
prompt so you take your original image
you segment it and then they're then re
redrawing on some new uh style so that's
the way this model works and this is the
one we're going to be
using so basically with these with these
it starts it starts very straightforward
to interact with them but there's quite
often people will build like a pipeline
like an AI pipeline of um how you how
you use these models so maybe you
wouldn't run it through this whole
process you might use from here to here
you might use one that does very nice
segmentation so you see here the
segmentation is a bit broken a bit like
Jagged it's not it's lost a lot of
detail so what you might want to use is
a better AI model to get to this
segmented stage and then a better model
to go from this segmentation to the
final product because you see here it
could be better in all honesty but this
is this is the way in which when people
talk about building AI models is on ai
ai pipeline should I say they connect
these different models together but
we're using one here which is kind of
off the-shelf but it will still get us
to some some output that we we'd like to
see so let's go back to our code and
explain what we're doing here so then
we're getting our output back and we're
in our session State still we we we're
adding this output into our session
State um further down so this is
actually within to to the right of our
um sidebar so all of if you imagine all
that code was basically working within
this sidebar but what we have here is
the main page and so we're back we've
indented back and this is where we're
going to be doing our main page so we're
saying if there's an image uh input
within the session State we want to show
that so we're saying St image so we're
adding an image to the web page we're
going to add to this input image so
that's the uploaded image so what I'm
going to do here is I'm just just going
to quickly demonstrate that by taking
this sample photo so let's click reveal
in finder so we're going to take this
photo of this apartment building we have
here and I'm just going to add this into
the upload box and we'll see here um
this has updated the um main page so
that's this section this is the section
this line of code where we're saying if
image input in the session state so in
that sidebar we're adding this image
into to the session State and it's being
uh it's being like listened to over here
and being found we're then going to
render our our image then what we have
is if we have an output in the session
state for all the output images we're
then going to render those as also an
image so we don't have any output yet
we've not ran our model um and we've not
received anything back from replicate so
this is currently not um active this
section is not active these two lines
this is being triggered to this if
statement however if there's no input
image input we're going to render this
which is basically just going to be
rendering those stock images we saw so
I'm not going to talk through too much
there but it's just um the examples and
then these images which we're actually
rendering from this image folder so I've
done this to add a bit of styling and a
bit of like intuitiveness to the
application to show people what it does
so you always want to think about this
if you're building applications like how
can someone just like arrive on it and
instantly understand what the tool is
for without needing to retraining or
something so here what I'm doing is I'm
basically just showing the out various
example outputs within from this list of
stock images here so we have some before
and after images which I'm basically
showing up so let's go back to building
redesign dop and we can now run this so
let's see what happens when we we
actually run this model so again amazing
that it's only just over 100 lines of
code but we've built something that
looks like quite um comprehensive here
so let's get our API key so we want to
go back to our API
tokens section and we want to copy this
so I'm going to copy this and bring it
over to my um dashboard and I'm going to
copy and I'm going to paste this in and
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
go back to my notion page and I'm just
going to read the next line which is
basically I want to copy this this
prompt restyle in art Novo on a street
with clear skies so this is the prompt
we're going to be using to restyle this
photo it's important we also say about
the environment so we want to also tell
this uh we want to tell the um AI model
we're using also about the surroundings
so not just the building um because
otherwise it could do something quite
creative with that like white space um
if we don't give it a
prompt related to that so what we're
seeing here is resty in art Novo and if
we look at like art Novo style it's a
little bit like this so um it's very
beautiful nice you see it a lot in like
Barcelona and places like that um and we
want it to look a little bit like this
so let's copy and paste that prompt in
here and I think we have everything now
to run the model so I'm I clicked render
new idea and it started running so we're
going to give this a few seconds to just
load up and now let's scroll down and
just have a look at the output so we can
see we've done the segmentation here
although yeah of course it could be much
clearer um it could be much better than
this but it's done the segmentation
reasonably well and now we have our
output image so it sort of captured the
idea of art Novo um let's rerender this
and let's just see what the next output
is um
because sometimes these models can be
temperamental especially when it hasn't
done the segmentation perfectly um these
can these can be quite unpredictable so
here what we'll see the original image
you see this section's R um been
segmented very nicely this front face it
seems to be a bit more challenging but
here we have our UVO building and I'd
say this is very nicely done um as like
a first draft but again the key thing
you'll see here is let's look where this
segmentation is is clearer it's nicer
we've we're getting a better level of
detail on this side where it's a bit
more unclear you have some sort of
hanging objects you'll see that it's
it's it's struggling more in these areas
where you have just this one dash line
you see here it's kind of breaking down
so the important thing is to get this
segmentation really good um and then
obviously other objects um will be more
challenging with this model so what you
might do if you wanted to build this up
to be more advanced is you might run
multiple different AI models which are
good at different things here and you
might segment these differently so you
might detect this as being one object um
send that to one particular type of
model uh for rendering and then um send
these to others so you sort of like
deconstruct and then rebuild it back
together so for the good AI apps this is
what they would do so but this is the
first draft this is all I wanted to show
you guys today to get started and to try
to inspire you for some kind of exciting
final project so that brings us to the
end of lesson number six so I hope that
it's been really exciting for you seeing
how accessible some of these AI
Technologies are and how you don't need
that much coding experience to be able
to actually get started so um if there
is anything you haven't quite followed
then please do go back and rewatch those
sections or reach out in the Discord
group uh for help there in the next
lesson what we're going to be talking
about is more on the legal side talking
about the different laws that are being
passed in countries meaning that uh
developers and users have to be aware of
some of these changing regulations and
what it means for them if they're either
building AI systems or using them so
I'll see you in the next lesson and I
hope also from this lesson that you feel
quite inspired for building a final
project you have some ideas to either
build on top of some of the templates of
code that we've given you or to even
create your own fresh project from start
so please do uh please do attempt that
and I'll see you in the next lesson